people love it when i ask about books
i don't know if uh whether technical
like legal or fiction non-fiction books
throughout your life
have had an impact on you if there's
something you could recommend
or something you could speak to about
something that inspired ideas
insights about this world complicated
world of ours
oh wow uh yeah so uh i i'll give you a a
couple
uh so one is uh contingency irony and
solidarity
by richard wardy he's a he's passed away
now but was a
uh philosopher uh at some of our major
institutions princeton
harvard stanford
contingency irony and solidarity at
least that's a book that really helped
me
work through
a series of thoughts so it stands for
the proposition that uh
that our most deeply held beliefs uh
are contingent that there
there's nothing uh beyond history or
prior to socialization
that's definatory of the the the human
being that's rory
um and he says that uh our most deeply
held beliefs
are received wisdom and highly
contingent along a
a number of registers and he does that
but then goes on to say that
he nonetheless can hold strongly held
beliefs recognizing their contingency
but still believes them to be true and
accurate and it helps you to work
through
what could be an intellectual tension
uh other words so so you don't delve
into
one doesn't delve into relativism uh
everything is okay
but he gives you a vocabulary to think
about uh
uh uh how to negotiate these these these
realities uh
do you share this tension i mean there
there is a real
tension it seems like even like the law
the legal system is all just a construct
of our
human ideas and yet it seems to be
uh almost feels fundamental
to what a uh what a just society is yeah
i i definitely share share the tension
and and and love
the the uh uh his his vocabulary and the
way he's
uh helped me resolve the the tension so
right i mean yeah yeah so like you know
uh
infanticide for example perhaps it's
uh socially contingent perhaps it's
received
wisdom perhaps it's anthropological uh
you know we need to propagate this
species and i still think it's wrong
yeah and and and and rorty uh has helped
me develop a category to say
to to say that no i can't provide
any in rorty's words non-circular
theoretical
backup for this proposition at some
point it's going to run me into
in a circularity problem but that's okay
i'm i i i hold this nonetheless and full
recognition of its contingency but what
it does is
is is makes you humble
and and when you're humble that's good
because
you know this notion that ideas are
always already in
progress never fully formed uh i think
is
is is the sort of intellectual i strive
to be
and if i have a a a
sufficient degree of humility that i
don't have the
final answer capital a
then that's going to help me to get to
better answers lowercase a
and and rorty does that and he talks
about
uh in in the solidarity part of the book
he has this concept of
imaginative uh uh the imaginative
ability
to see other different people as we
instead of they and i just think it's a
beautiful concept but he talks about
this imaginative ability and it's this
active
process so i mean so that's a book
that's done a lot of work
uh uh for me uh over the
the years
you